yes friends we got some Joker news and
he taught me about Joker news I like
talking about the Joker so if there's
really profound Joker news or important
Joker news I'll probably do a video but
not always but sometimes is one of those
times
sorry I haven't reviewed skyscraper but
for the past few days I've been in san
jose del cabo great plays beautiful
plays we had a lot of fire on myself a
little bit of a tan but it probably
still looked like a zombie because i
just got in and it was a nonstop flight
that had a layover that they didn't call
a layover they simply called it landing
the plane in a city that's not the
destination to go through customs only
to sit around the airport for a couple
of hours get back on the plane then fly
to Seattle but it's not a layover who's
toddler sounds like a layover twenties
it's late I don't have time to watch
skyscraper I have a busy weekend in
Seattle and dr. path traveler just came
out I mean come on I'll be honest with
you I might have missed skyscraper
forever I don't know talk about the
junker and apparently Joaquin Phoenix
it's actually signed on to play the
Joker and a standalone Joker movie Jared
Leto is still apparently the Joker but
there's just a completely detached thing
and it's an origin story when I talked
about this it was about ten months ago I
was like I don't want to see a Joker
origin story I'm interested in what they
can do with this but I don't want to see
a joker origin story after walking
Phoenix was signed on like Joaquin
Phoenix sold me on it not the origin
story necessarily it being a detached
thing even if you don't like the origin
story you still have Jared Leto's Joker
you still add the dark knight who again
I've always been the naysayer when it
comes to a Joker origin story because
not knowing his origin makes him a
little creepier you don't know where the
guys coming from I like that it's very
intriguing but hearing they want to make
this smaller budget character piece
starring Joaquin Phoenix that kind of
changes my tongue is an angle I didn't
think they would go and apparently
they're doing it like I would rather
them make a movie that doesn't feel like
a comic book movie doesn't feel like a
joker movie keep the budget low enough
it's like they're forced to make a
character page a lot of Studios would
sweat like we can't make the big
splosions and the I think the MCU hasn't
had good characters in their big-budget
comic book movie they've had some great
characters with some great moments I
feel like that's another thing entirely
I think it'd be a neat take I feel like
that's what Sony wants to do with the
venom movie I think that's a good call
he's saying it's a good call doesn't
mean the movie is going to be great if
the movie does suck I still think it's a
good call you can make a good call and
not stick the landing those are two
completely separate things separate
argument so I hope the Phantom movies
good I know this Joker movies good also
it being an origin story it makes me
think is Joaquin Phoenix going to be the
Joker as he's been the Joker for a while
and it goes back to show his origin
maybe he's younger is it gonna be a
different actor
I'd like to see Joaquin Phoenix do both
I'm just saying walking Phoenix isn't
like the youngest human ever not the
oldest neither I'm just saying I I feel
like he'd be a joker who's been the
Joker for a bit so if you're gonna show
his origin you're gonna show it in
flashback scenes it's gonna be
chronological I feel like the best thing
they could have done with this is past
its time and that would be we wouldn't
even be talking about it because we
wouldn't know this is a joker origin
story
it'd be like Joaquin Phoenix is doing
this small movie about this wrecked man
and then people watch it in the end of
like oh my god that's a joker origin
story that'd be the greatest twist ever
I mean the time I've seen that as
Shyamalan if you haven't seen split si
split I'll still try to keep it vacates
you haven't seen split but you should
see split Shyamalan could have been like
oh by the way it's tied into this and
more people would have seen the movie
but he was like I'll just do it and then
I want to blow some minds at the end he
didn't it that was really effective I
could have been the best thing they
could have done with a joker origin
story but it's not gonna be because now
we know what's happening now we know
Joaquin Phoenix is going to be the Joker
so everyone's gonna have their eyes on
it I feel like this thing could gain
momentum to be a runaway train at some
point it's gonna be this 50 million
dollar character piece it's now a
big-budget comic-book movie like all the
rest and I feel like Joaquin Phoenix
would shut that down if he could
and if he couldn't he'd probably just
try to walk away from it so based on his
excitement for the movie should show
what they're doing with the movie
whether or not is still in line with
what walking Phoenix wanted in the first
place he'll make it his own thing he is
method as hell I don't think he's gonna
mail dead rats to people because you
don't need to do that it's not about
that that that's a stick I don't think
Joaquin Phoenix is gonna make it a stick
by the end I feel like walking Phoenix
will know more about the Joker than any
of us and that really excites me that
you have an actor who really cares for
nothing else this small budget Joker
origin story with an actor who will take
it seriously shows me a large element of
maturity and adaptation from Warner
Brothers and DC we live in a world where
a lot of people feel that you take
people's mistakes and they're just their
mistakes are there to talk on
Twitter because likes and retweets baby
but I really feel it's important to keep
mistakes in perspective if you make a
mistake whether you're a human being or
a studio you should take pride in your
mistakes be like oh I made that huge
mistake I will take that information and
proceed accordingly I will learn from
that mistake how great is that mistake
that it's an opportunity to learn so I
wasn't there among the DC board meetings
or meeting rooms or anything like that
and I imagine they saw Marvel doing the
cinematic universe and they were like we
need to catch up and they didn't quite
do it the best way possible so now
they're forced to think what does Marvel
Studios not
well thus far Marvel Studios has not
done the very personal low-budget
approach to one of their villains there
may be Marvel Studios movies that have
done villains very well but that's very
different than what we're talking about
with this Joker movie this sounds like
Joker movie in the vein of unbreakable
or something that's actually really cool
that's learning from your mistakes I
really want this movie to do well I mean
I do well I mean be good and do well and
if this is good critically acclaimed
lands with the fans and is financially
successful and that might tell other
studios out there like hey you can do
that too you can do a good character
piece keep it low budget people like
that holy you can actually do an
Obie one movie that people will want to
see so if you're like right now Lucas
films like obi-wan Kenobi but low budget
does not just like they just drive
circuit or something I'm not saying
there haven't been superhero movies or
movies in superhero universes that
didn't concentrate on the character I'm
not saying there aren't superhero movies
with comparatively smaller budgets like
Deadpool comes to mind but those movies
still feel like they're from their
respective universe I would love for
this Joker origin story to not feel like
a DC Universe movie I don't want to feel
like Batman's just around the corner if
this movie does well it could be a good
lesson to a lot of Studios that yeah you
don't have to do the comic book movie
big-budget crazy summer action
blockbuster you can do it in other ways
I think that's are important also glass
by Shyamalan I think for a lot of those
reasons a lot of eyes are gonna be on
that too what does I'm interested Joker
origin story never asked for it Joaquin
Phoenix coming onto it I feel like
that's legit I don't feel like he'll
stand for some by still walking
Phoenix doing a joker standalone movie
in the way they apparently want to do it
have you heard about it what do you
think about it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more funny have you heard it you
just did there's no way you got to this
point didn't hear about it after hearing
me talk about that was dumb
[Music]